[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
johnny is doing great we
facetimed him right after the verdict
and
it looked like the weight of the world
is off of his shoulders
fresh off a winning verdict law and
crime network sits down with johnny
depp's famed attorney and the murdoch
murder mystery why officials will soon
exhume the body of alec murdoch's former
housekeeper plus survivors of larry
nassau's sexual abuse say the fbi
botched its investigation how much they
are seeking in damages and later uvalde
texas is where i was born
i swear my
my mom taught kindergarten less than a
mile from robb elementary actor matthew
mcconaughey addresses the deadly school
shooting in a white house briefing law
on crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Applause]
[Music]
fresh off the heels of an overwhelming
victory in the high-profile defamation
suit viewed around the world johnny
depp's attorney ben chu speaks to the
law and crime network for the first time
after weeks of testimony the johnny depp
amber heard trial ended in a win for
both actors with a jury finding mostly
in favor of depp the jury awarded depp
10 million dollars in compensatory
damages and 5 million in punitive
damages over heard claiming to be a
victim of domestic abuse in a 2018
washington post op-ed article heard also
won part of the countersuit when she was
awarded 2 million in compensatory
damages and nothing for punitive damages
over comments made by depp's attorney
adam waldman just one week after the
verdict was announced long crime
network's jesse weber sat down with
depp's attorney ben chu chu explained
how the team prepared depp for his
lengthy testimony and why he was
emotional as the verdict was read
we were nervous in the sense that
he
writes all of his i mean he writes his
scripts when he is performing roles and
this is no different i mean we had
suggestions as any attorneys would but
ultimately what he says is
all in his own words
so
um
we knew or we strongly believe that he
was
going to be consistent with everything
and and truthful
and so in that sense we weren't that
worried about him and he didn't have to
be
uh
reminded about dates and events i mean
his memory is quite clear
about what happened and what did not
happen i thought he was terrific
and what about under cross examination
by benjamin rottenborn you know got
tense at times
what were your thoughts on how to cross
well our main concern as with any
witness is that he not loses cool
because we knew that they would come at
him with a male and in this case ben
rottenborn so when we practice we had
one of our senior attorneys wayne
dennison come in and play the role
of attack dog and so i think johnny was
prepared for that and i think he kept
his composure
under cross i think you did a very good
job
we didn't want to be presumptuous enough
to think that we were winning because
it's very hard to read the jury
but we did think that johnny's direct
testimony and his performance on cross
was excellent and
we also were happy with camille
vasquez's masterful cross-examination of
of of amber heard and we think the
contrast there
was
one of them was willing to take
accountability
and one of them appeared less willing to
be accountable for certain things and
appear to have
convenient answers for everything you
hear the verdict a win on each one of
johnny depp's claims
what was your reaction
it was emotional i mean it was
we were so thrilled for him
that was great
joining us today is l.a county deputy
public defender phillip dube and co-host
terry austin phillip you've tried cases
and with so much press around this trial
before during and now after how in-depth
of a look into this trial is this
oh it was very uh first of all it was a
very lengthy trial and they're very
rarely televised and you rarely actually
see celebrities on trial in a full-blown
trial
usually counsel will appear on their
behalf at various hearings but when it
comes down to it and they're a party to
the litigation and both sides can't
settle then both sides are there but we
rarely see this much uh camera activity
in the courtroom this much couture very
very well-behaved council and frankly
even the judge looked like she had you
know some cameos and pearls on and a
little war paint frankly to be camera
ready uh but often times in the real
world you know the parties can be quite
redundant they keep repeating themselves
but the judge had a pretty tight reign
on these lawyers and kept it moving at
least so uh i think it was a pretty fair
exemplar but for some of the celebrity
aspects of the trial makes sense i would
agree as well
terry any surprises or new insight on
the trial after hearing true sit down
with jesse
i expected that depp was going to be
well prepared after all his firm brown
rudnick the lawyers who represented deaf
is an excellent firm but i didn't know
and we learned that johnny depp did
prepare his own answers so for a fact
i'm sure the lawyers scripted the
questions but we learned that johnny
depp actually scripted the narrative and
that makes a lot of sense if he's
telling the truth if it's his story if
he scripts that narrative and he sticks
to it it's going to be genuine he's
going to come across well and the jury
is going to believe him so i think the
prep was excellent they told him what to
anticipate and he told his story to that
jury yeah usually you have to work your
client into telling the story pull it
out of them but when you have a client
giving a story like that it rings that
much true and it's a lot less work i can
see philip smiling in agreement it's a
lot less work for the defense switching
now from a movie actors to reality tv
stars as the grizzly knows best
headliners are found guilty of fraud and
tax evasion
todd and julie crisley the married
couple best known for their reality tv
show chrisley knows bess were found
guilty by a federal jury in atlanta on
tuesday jurors found the couple guilty
of conspiring to defraud community banks
of more than 30 million dollars in
fraudulent loans
a release from the department of justice
says the couple used the money to buy
designer clothes luxury cars and real
estate property the doj also says the
grizzlies did not file tax returns or
pay any taxes between 2013 and 2016.
prosecutors say the couple faked credit
reports and bank statements and use a
film production company to hide their
income from the irs right now the couple
is free on bond but are required to wear
gps monitoring systems the pair is
expected to be sentenced in october
and a 12 year old boy is in police
custody after allegedly robbing a gas
station at gunpoint last week
surveillance video shows the boy walking
up to the checkout counter with a
backpack in one hand and concealing a
gun in the other after waiting for the
man in front of him to check out he
brandishes the gun and quietly tells the
cashier to put the money in the bag the
cashier can be heard asking are you
serious take a look at what happens next
[Music]
[Music]
take it
[Music]
police say the boy stole a gun from his
grandfather from a locked cabinet in his
home they say he was caught shortly
after the robbery nearby
still ahead on law and crime daily larry
nassar's survivors say the fbi botched a
sexual abuse investigation but first one
year after the double homicide rocked
south carolina the murders of paul and
maggie murdoch are still unsolved
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back this week's marks
one year since the murder of the wife
and son of south carolina disgrace
attorney alec murdoch that anniversary
comes just days after the family of his
former housekeeper agreed to have her
body exhumed for re-examination the body
of murdoch's former housekeeper gloria
stattersfield will be exhumed as part of
a new investigation into her mysterious
death statterfield died in february 2018
at the murdoch's south carolina home it
was initially ruled a falling accident
this renewed interest in her manner of
death comes amid murdoch facing a slew
of fraud charges including allegedly
stealing a more than four million dollar
settlement made with statterfield's sons
after her death and faking his own
murder in order to collect a 10 million
dollar insurance payout for his son the
bosch murder plot came just a day after
murdoch was accused of stealing millions
of dollars from former clients murdoch
has not been charged in relation to
statusfield's death one year after the
murder of his wife and son no arrests
have been made in that case either
terry it's been a year since paul and
maggie murdock deaths and we don't seem
to be any closer to solving their
murders why do you think that is
you know i kind of understand brian why
it's taking so long this case involves
so many moving parts you have the death
of gloria satterfield the housekeeper
you have don't forget the death of
mallory beach who was in that boat crash
involving murdoch's son paul
you have the civil suits that are being
brought by satterfield and beach
families you have insurance fart you
have embezzlement as far as the client
funds are concerned you have the deadly
shooting obviously of maggie and the sun
and don't forget he staged his own
suicide and there's a third party
involved so the authorities are looking
at all of this trying to put it together
trying to see if there are any pieces
that they can tie into each other so
it's going to take a while absolutely
now phil gloria statofield's body will
be exhumed but she's been buried for so
long so what do you expect we will learn
and what will still may be a mystery
after her body is exhumed
well once the body is exhumed it will be
in the care of that particular county
coroner's office and i anticipate that
they will either hold what's called a
coroner's inquest
where they will present bits and pieces
of evidence to an actual jury
to decide whether or not uh what the
cause of death is and whether or not
it's a homicide
for now what it's showing is that it was
natural causes from a fall but i
anticipate that the coroner uh that the
jury as part of this inquest or even a
forensic anthropologist is going to look
at the skeletal remains to look to see
if there was blunt force trauma anywhere
on the head or anywhere maybe in the
spinal column and also do toxicology
studies on the skeletal remains to see
if there was any poison or other foul
play all right we'll see what those
results bring up and thank you for that
list coming up on law and crime daily a
famous actor makes a plea for stricter
gun control laws in the united states
plus survivors of larry nassar's sexual
abuse say the fbi bought its
investigation how much money they're now
seeking for law enforcement
[Music]
welcome back survivors of lair nassar's
abuse are now seeking one billion
dollars from the fbi saying officials
delay the investigation into nassar
after receiving multiple reports
dozens of girls and women maintained
nassar sexually assaulted them as
children while working as their
gymnastics doctor olympic gymnast simone
biles and michaela moroney are among the
nearly 100 women and girls now filing
tort claims against the fbi saying its
investigation was botched back in 2021
four olympic gymnasts testified before
the u.s senate saying fbi agents
mishandled the investigation by making
false statements and ignoring reports of
abuse for years nassar who worked for
decades as a team doctor for michigan
state university and usa gymnastics was
convicted on multiple accounts including
sexual assault of a child and possession
of child pornography he's now serving a
60-year sentence on child pornography
charges he also faces a separate
sentence of 40 to 175 years in state
prison for seven counts of criminal
sexual conduct
terry what type of evidence should we
expect to support or see to support
sorry the claims by the former gymnast
against the fbi
there is a slew of evidence brian
they're alleging that the fbi actually
mishandled the nassar investigation and
they're suing under the federal tort
claims act which makes any employee of
the united states liable if they are
negligent well here all they have to do
is look at the report from the inspector
general which said that there was
negligence that the fbi
failed to properly investigate and so if
they are able
to bring that into the case that's going
to be
all of the evidence that they need
because it's going to actually show that
the fbi was contacted and they did
nothing to investigate the case yeah
philip with all we know about larry
nassar and the fbi's involvement or lack
thereof should we expect a settlement
here or maybe changes in how the fbi
works or a full-blown trial
if a motion for summary judgment in
favor of the fbi is denied it will
settle but i anticipate this is going to
be more of a legal test
fbi agents under uh the federal tort
claims act enjoy what's called the um
discretionary duty doctrine meaning that
if they perform an act that requires
discretion on their part in other words
it's not a mandatory duty to act and you
cannot be microphoned for failing to act
you cannot be faulted at all
so i anticipate that if this was a
discretionary act in other words in
choosing not to further investigate and
there is no law or policy or regulation
on point that directs the fbi to
investigate these claims i think their
lawsuits will be dismissed agreed as
well well we'll see how it plays out
when we come back an emotional plea for
stricter gun control laws uvalde texas
native and famed actor matthew
mcconaughey calls for policy change
following the deadly school shooting
[Music]
welcome back academy award-winning actor
matthew mcconaughey makes an impassioned
speech at the white house following the
deadly school shooting in his hometown
of uvalde texas
19 students and two teachers were shot
and killed on may 24th when an
18 year old gunman opened fire in the
school 17 others were injured the gunman
used an ar-15 style rifle to shoot and
injure his grandmother before making his
way to the school he entered through an
unlocked side door and remained inside
for more than an hour as multiple
students inside the building called
9-1-1 he was later shot and killed by
border patrol agents mcconaughey who was
born in uvalde texas says he visited the
city just one day after the shooting he
says his mother taught kindergarten just
one mile from robb elementary school at
a white house address on tuesday
mcconaughey called for stricter gun
control requirements the actor got
emotional when explaining how one
student's body was identified
you could feel the shock
in the town
you could feel the pain
the denial the disillusion anger blame
sadness loss of lives dreams halted
we saw ministries we saw
first responders counselors cooks
families trying to grieve without it
being on the front page news
we met with the local funeral director
and countless morticians who who hadn't
slept since the massacre the day before
because they've been working 24 7 trying
to handle so many bodies at once
so many little
innocent bodies
who had their entire lives still yet to
live
maite wore
green high top converse
with a heart she had hand drawn on the
right toe because they represented her
love
of nature camilla's got these shoes can
you show these shoes please
wear these every day
green converse with a heart on the right
toe
this is the same green converse
on her feet that turned out to be the
only clear evidence that could identify
her after the shooting
we need to invest in mental health care
we need to save for schools
we need to restrain sensationalized
media coverage
we need to restore our family values
we need to restore
our american values
and
we need responsible gun ownership
responsible gun ownership we need
background checks
we need to raise the minimum age to
purchase an ar-15 rifle
2 21
we need a waiting period for those
rifles we need red flag laws and
consequences for those who abuse them
these are reasonable practical tactical
regulations
meanwhile the department of justice
announced it's launching a critical
review of the law enforcement response
following the deadly shooting in a
release the doj says the review would
work to provide an account of the law
enforcement response identify lessons
learned from that response and work to
outline the best practices for future
first responders involved in similar
incidents since the shooting law
enforcement has faced backlash for its
response time many noting it took
officers one hour and 17 minutes to
break into the school after the gunman
first walked inside the doj now says its
office of communities oriented policing
services will conduct the review
philip where do you think the doj will
start their investigation into the
evolving police response to this mass
shooting
well the good news is it's a critical
review and not a criminal probe the
first thing that they're going to do is
they're going to look at the time of the
call for help
the time of arrival
how many deaths occurred before they
forced entry into that final room where
the gunman was killed
ultimately i think the doj is going to
put this local police department on a
path toward avoiding a receivership so
they know what best practices to use if
god forbid in the future they ever have
another mass murder anywhere be it a
market school anywhere in public
you know it's heartbreaking to think
that we're preparing for the next one
but terry what was your take away from
mcconaughey's speech and what action do
you think is needed next
you know i think mcconaughey was very
passionate he is from vivaldi i'm so
glad he came i'm so glad he spoke up and
i think people are listening to what he
had to say but i don't think it's enough
he talked about mental health care safer
schools restraining the media family
values all of those things are excellent
but at the end of the day he basically
said you know if you have an ar-15 raise
the age and make sure that you are not a
red flag risk but in my humble opinion i
don't think that anyone really needs an
ar-15 you don't need to have an ar-15 if
you're going hunting or even if you're
protecting your home so i do think we
need to start with what he said but i
think we should probably go further now
let's hope they'll make some steps going
forward in this crisis well thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you